let me go delete all the crap post that
this thing just automatically made for
me.
I think it's just our wired internet
just being crapped here. We'll try it on
Wi-Fi, which ironically should be more
stable.
We should be able to get rid of all this
stuff.
including
We're going to rename the MV, I guess to
drone race.
Make sure the stream is stable.
Looks good.
No, I think it's okay.
category does not seem to be persistent.
Lovely.
Yeah, you're right. Let's see. This is
why I don't do it cuz literally every
time it does anything, I have to redo
it. But
It should hopefully be stable now. I'm
pretty sure it's just that we have like
jank Ethernet cables, like jank
connections or jank something here.
Whatever. I don't want to deal with it.
It should be good. We'll just do it on
Wi-Fi. Should be good enough.
Okay, so we need this random ring
function
I must have gotten rid of. Let me go
grab it.
Oh yeah, star the puffer lip. Star the
puffer if you haven't. It helps us out a
lot. It's free.
I say we just put this into the um
drone lab, right?
So, yeah. So, that wasn't that hard,
right?
I don't know if it's actually using the
drone.
Yeah, it's probably not using the drone
though. It's just using these like
random functions.
So, let's fix that.
Yeah. You see this has like position,
previous position.
So, what we're going to do is we'll just
do drone drone like this.
And drone does have position, right?
Let's just check.
Oh, it does need previous position up.
Okay, so we'll just do
Holy Yeah, there's going to have to be a
lot of substitutions.
What's going to happen though
eventually, right? We're going to get to
a point where these look similar enough
that we can just make it like either one
end with configs
or something.
We can kind of just train on a ton of
different tasks. Like the RL is kind of
good enough that if we just give it a
lot of tasks for drones, as long as it's
fast and they're reasonably posed, it
should just work.
The RL side's very good at this point.
It's mostly just about getting the Sims
uh to be built better and faster.
We're uh planning on improving the
physics.
Awesome.
So, my plan, Sam, you can tell me if you
think that this makes sense here. So,
we're going to want to do a lot of
different stuff with these drones to
test them out. We're gonna have to do
like the ring racing task. We'll do
swarming stuff. We'll do like obstacle
avoidance. We can do tons of stuff. I'm
gonna try to I don't want to modularize
stuff a whole bunch to the point that it
becomes heavy. All I want to do is just
take like the drone physics and all the
parts about the drone control and then
separate those from the task specifics.
So, we can just have a couple hundred
line like drone.h with all the physics
or whatever. And then we can just
include that in whatever other Sims we
want to build around it, right? Whatever
other task, whatever other Sims. And
maybe eventually we will converge on
like one set of observations or, you
know, maybe we'll find other ways to
unify things. But I'm not going to worry
about that too much initially. I just
want to make sure that we have one spot
for at least like the physics and such.
Um, and I think that'll help us out
quite a bit because then I'm going to
start like I'm going to start
introducing randomized versions of
these, right? Or like I'm going to add
randomization parameters.
So you can just say all right uh
whenever the drone moves, right? Let's
just screw with the physics by a small
delta.
And the idea is that if it can if it can
behave under all sorts of different
small perturbations, it should just
behave well generally.
We'll also do the same type of stuff for
like the drone size and so on and so
forth.
I'm going to try to do this without
making it any heavier or any harder for
you guys to use.
That's the goal.
So I'm running uh research side support.
plot li. Yeah, we're just not going to
try to like worry about it too much
initially though, right? like
over modularizing is just the way that
you break everything. I don't want to do
that. I just want to have the physics
separated cleanly because of the
randomization work
just so we're not like know copy pasting
all the lines into the file and like
having two different versions of physics
delay largely unnecessary. Uh I actually
don't know about that. It depends on how
good of a controller you have.
Like I think you still might need to do
something with if it's like 50 ms delay
that might be a lot, right?
If you get like 10 ms delay, I think we
should be good.
I just don't know like with 50.
Also, my mic is super loud. Hang on.
Let's not clip. Let's not clip the mic
too much.
Yeah. Plus, this is kind of chill today.
We kind of just get to like chill and
improve our own code.
Just invest a little bit into the uh
the core.
transmitter is really good, but we need
to see.
Uh delay is like slightly inconvenient.
But it's not that bad.
I think that the best thing we can do is
in parallel if you guys get the drone
flying and you can like run commands on
it
then um
and I can get the sim to be really
robust.
We should be pretty pretty good.
Welcome to all the YouTube folks, the
people who just got here. We're
currently working on the uh well both of
the drone environments.
One of which is
uh this warm sim right here and the
other of which is a racing environment
that looks like
like this.
We're doing a little bit of work on just
getting the code to be easier and
cleaner across both of these. And then
we're going to do some work on domain
randomization that's going to make it a
heck of a lot easier to make this work
on a real drone.
In fact, you know, one thing that I
think is going to be really cool about
this is if I do this correctly, it
should work on like a ton of different
types of drones. Like we probably the
best case scenario, right, is that we'll
just be able to buy different drones and
hook this up and not even really have to
do any work specific to each drone.
Are you planning to track the drone
position back relative to the start
position? Yeah. So, for now,
right for now, we're probably just going
to do everything relative. Um, so we'll
just see if we can like get it to fly
around in some patterns. We are going to
have to do perception for the real
hardware at some point, but like it's
not going to be end to end RL division,
right? It's probably just going to be
some sort of basic state estimation at
least to start.
I'm just it's worth spending some time
cleaning this up because we're actually
going to use this for
quite a bit of stuff
and um
I don't want to make like I don't want
this code to be a mess. Just causes us
problems.
To be fair, they submitted me Finn and
Sam submitted me very clean code. Um, I
kind of made a mess of it in the process
of making it multi- aent, but like it
should be very possible to keep it m
like to make it multi- aent and just as
simple as before, if not simpler
Oh, that's so funny. Ghost uh ghost TTY
renders it renders these arrows as like
the arrow character in the term. It's
funny.
Conveniently, we have the pre-trained
model loaded into C, so I can know
exactly if I break it. Right. As long as
I don't modify ops, I shouldn't have to
break it at all.
Let's take a look through here. We still
have 500 lines of stuff somehow. And a
lot of this we should be able to
a lot a lot of this we should be able to
kind of just stick into the main
uh the main thing.
Let's do if we just assume we make the
end logic multi- aent.
We assume we make it multi- aent by
default.
I think we should just assume we make it
multi- aent by default, right?
We'll separate out stuff like collision
checking, right?
I am new. Are you writing an N?
Uh, I'm editing an N.
I'm definitely making changes to an N.
Drone racing ends and drone swarming
ends. Both of these.
Oh, yeah. Also, for the new folks around
here, we do have there's like 25 plus
pages of uh reinforcement learning intro
material that will go live as soon as
this hits 10K. So go ahead and follow
this on X if you want RL content and you
want that guide.
if we assume it's multi- aent
then basically
almost all this code should just be
directly usable, right?
Pretty
much the actual code here, this drone
race code is just going to be like the
100 lines or whatever it is to wire it
together.
We can probably get most of this
uh most of this code to be separated out
cleanly.
Take a little bit of work, but we can do
it. And it's worth the it's worth doing
the work.
Let's like look for end in here. We
don't use the end until the out of
bounds checks at all.
Then all of this logic down to here just
goes into a move function.
The ring stuff is a bit more
complicated,
this function is going into the drone
level.
We can probably get the ring logic to be
standalone if we try.
It's just the fact that that's hardcoded
right now, right?
Oh yeah, this is just like
jank, right?
Yeah, this is just jank the way this is
written.
Yeah. Pause and normal,
right?
Okay. Yeah, I didn't realize that this
was done this way.
That's better. Let's see if I broke
anything in the process of doing that.
No, not at all. Okay, so that's like the
checks are actually very simple. It was
just really verbose because they didn't
make a ring variable.
So, we can just make like a check ring
or whatever.
I see.
So all I have to do is I have to take
more of this logic and put it in there.
Okay.
So like all this
somehow
and then this we'll make this a float.
Okay.
and then what I'll do I see what we're
going to do
so we'll here what we'll do is we'll do
float reward
check ring
do r start ring
okay and then like something like this
so we'll do if reward
Z
We set the terminal. We add log
like this.
Okay.
Something like this should be fine.
nonvoid function does not return a
value.
Now I think we know the uh the routine
here, right? This just goes into drone
li now.
We got 300 lines. I'm fine with the
drone li being a little longer if it's
going to include all the objects, right?
Cuz we'll probably put like collision
obstacles in there. We can put like
sphere collision obstacles, right? So,
it has to like route around an obstacle
field. We can do lots of stuff
technically, right? We could do like,
you know, like the Asteroids game. We
could do that with the drone. That'd be
pretty cool.
Actually, we should do that. Like I
actually have um like asteroids thing
but with real drone physics.
Be cool.
Okay. What else is in here?
probably all this stuff about camera
control
I mean this is directly copy pasted
right
just do this
it's literally the same thing.
We might want to do like separate stuff
later, right?
But we'll for now we'll just put it into
drone lib.
Oh, but we don't have the client
defined, so we can't actually do that.
Yeah, actually that's a little less
trivial,
at least for now.
We've already made this a heck of a lot
easier though.
Let me just make the other file like the
drone swarm work and then so we don't
spend too long just refactoring right
now. We'll do we'll start on a little
randomization type stuff.
I should have gotten a policy in here,
but it's okay.
So we do drone swarm
Yeah, you see I have the exact exact
same dynamics here.
It's a little strong.
So idea here should be
just do this
Yeah. And then what I have to do is I
have to copy. I have to be very careful
with this actually. So this is what I'm
going to do.
Okay, so this still works. So now we
have the movement function with all the
physics.
I'm going to do this. We'll do this for
drone race even.
We want to randomize quite a bit of this
stuff. I'm trying to think what we want
to randomize per episode versus what we
want to randomize per step.
going to do a quick little brief
introduction to um
I can do like a quick little
introduction to domain randomization if
folks are interested in that.
So the paper to read for domain
randomization especially in control if
you're interested
it's this result.
I was at OpenAI when this work was being
done. I didn't interact a ton with the
robotics team except at lunch.
Um but if you look at what this is, you
see how they just have tons of different
versions of this. You don't just
randomize the color, you randomize the
physics, you randomize everything. And
the idea is that you can't exactly
simulate the real world,
right? You can do your best to try to
simulate the real world exactly, but
you're going to fail. Now, what you
might be able to do, right, is you might
be able to make a noisy sim where like
the robot learns to behave in enough
different scenarios that it doesn't
really have to exactly match the real
world because it's going to just be
robust enough anyways.
Uh, this is a very very effective
technique. It's been used in tons and
tons of different areas.
Actually, they tell you right here
object dimensions,
link masses, surface friction
coefficients,
damping coefficients, actuator force
gain,
joint limits, gravity vector.
These are actually very big
randomizations.
Keep in mind like the RL wasn't as good
back then, so they had to really crank
this to make this thing work. can also
like humanoid hands are not super easy
either. It's like a pretty high degree
of freedom problem.
So actually I'd say most of the problem
of humanoids is in the hands, not the
rest of the robot
and more degrees of freedom in the hands
and the rest of the robot for most
models.
Okay.
So knowing that
I think we do a per episode
randomization
it'll be easier and I think it'll cover
pretty much the whole use case.
We will see if I'm correct on that. But
I think it should cover just about the
whole use case.
Do you recommend reinforcement learning?
Is that the original book or is that a
new book? Is that like the original
Sutton and Bardo book or is that a new
one?
Yeah, this is the original book. So,
it really depends, Jason.
If you have a mathematically heavy
background and a weak programming
background, you might find that a decent
way to learn. The thing is it covers a
ton of mathematical background. Um,
which is good,
but at least the way that I've
approached things, it's most of the math
doesn't actually work. So, it's going to
give you the impression that
reinforcement learning is like this very
well theoretically justified, cleancut
field, and it's really not. like none of
the math actually works.
Where I've come from, I found it way
easier to just treat reinforcement
learning as an almost purely empirical
field, right? Like an almost purely
empirical field. Just completely ignore
the MDP formalism of everything. Yeah,
we still we still write some formulas,
but they're models more than anything
else, and they're like really bad models
at the best of times.
If you look at my quick start guide,
you're going to see the types of things
that I generally recommend to newcomers,
which are actually a lot more accessible
mathematically and are going to get you
writing a lot more code on things that
work very quickly. So, if you check my
quick start guide, that's a good
resource. You can you can decide from
there what you think on the more formal
material. Also, probably within the next
day or two, as soon as this hits 10K,
as soon as this number hits 10K, I'm
releasing my own guide, which is like 25
pages of material on uh programming, ML
engineering, and then mostly the
majority of the material is on how to
learn reinforcement learning. It's like
a very step-by-step guide on read this,
implement this, so on and so forth.
I didn't miss any meetings today. I hope
right.
No,
Hey Tyler,
welcome.
We are doing drone things today.
Oh yeah, I forget who it was, but there
is a second um we've got like a second
physicist around who's been watching
some of the streams.
That was a cool thing.
I say we just make all these things
properties of the drone,
right? And we just make all these things
properties of the drone.
We're not bothered as long as it works.
I'm trying to make it also very simple
as well.
We're going to make these properties of
the drone.
Okay.
And then we'll just do
float,
And you know what we can even do? I'll
tell you what. We
know I don't want to leave these
constants in as the problem.
Keep the unit comments. Oh yeah. Oops.
My bad.
Okay. Do we have like rand?
Yeah. Rand F.
I should probably do like base instead
of doing it this way. Yeah, let's do it
this way.
Hang on.
That way we don't drive you guys totally
crazy.
I just need to make sure I change the
names of these because otherwise like
you know there's going something is
still going to be using the originals.
Okay. So that domain randomizes the
entire the entire drone
DT can stay the same.
I think DT is going to need to get
randomized, but
DT might even need to get randomized
every step, honestly,
cuz you're not going to have precise
control intervals.
But we're going to just like start like
this.
I mean once we get this hooked up
correctly it's actually running domain
randomization experiments can be made
very very easy if you know how to do it
correctly. It's very hard if you don't
these norms.
This should not break the policy though.
At least it won't break it when we set
DR to zero. That's the goal. Like the
goal is that the policy shouldn't break
until we crank DR up
RPM.
Well, that's a bit much, huh?
That's funny.
Okay, so this is look with no domain
randomization. It works perfectly. I
suspect I just did it kind of stupidly.
Yeah, see this is plus RNG.
This should be 1.0F
minus DR and 1.0F plus DR. And then it
should be times RNG.
I wanted to do 10% randomization not
not.1 flat randomization.
Uhoh.
My computer just froze.
That's weird.